an ongoing story in terms of the
Republican Party is the growing list of
Republicans who will not support who
will not endorse who will not vote for
Donald Trump the presumptive nominee of
the Republican Party and the new thing
is that Republicans of varying levels of
notoriety are leaving the Republican
Party all together over Donald Trump so
i think that there's a sort of tier
louis where tier one would be I'm a
Republican I'm going to vote for Trump
but I don't like it and then tier 2 is
I'm a Republican and I'm not going to
vote for Trump but I will remain a
Republican and tier 3 which is what I
call going nuclear in some sense is I am
leaving the Republican Party because
Donald Trump is the nominee George will
the well-known conservative writer
George will is no longer a Republican he
revealed this last week in a meeting
with the federalist society where he
said quote I changed my registration to
unaffiliated 23 days ago I hardly made
an announcement i just mentioned this in
a meeting with the federalist society i
left for the same reason i joined in
1964 when I voted for Barry Goldwater I
joined it because I was a conservative
but I will leave for the same reason
that I'm a conservative and Donald Trump
does not represent that saying after
Trump went after the Mexican judge from
northern Indiana then Paul Ryan endorsed
him and I decided that in fact this is
not my party anymore what a trump do
insulted George will saying he's an
overrated political pundit lost his way
a long time ago and has left the
republican party after making many bad
calls and then we have iowa state
senator david johnson who also is no
longer a Republican saying I am a
Republican at heart but I don't think
it's enough to say I disagree with mr.
Trump or I find him offensive or
whatever and then a growing list of
Republicans who just aren't going to the
republican national convention in
Cleveland Ohio at all congressman trey
Gowdy i am not attending mark sanford
Republican from South Carolina I'm not
meaning I'm not attending the Republican
convention congressman Carlos curbelo
from Florida I won't be there and
congresswoman meal love from Utah who's
been seen as a potential vice
presidential contender saying to
Politico she is
going to skip the convention because she
sees no upsides this doesn't practically
change the political beliefs of anybody
right George will and David Johnson
whoever else they still hold the same
positions but they are so repulsed by
what is going on with Donald Trump that
they are no longer part of that party
where they going I I guess to two
independent bill I don't know a very
very unique circumstances this year it
is I don't understand why it takes
Donald Trump to push these people out of
the party right the party has been
completely repulsive and disgusting and
an abhorrent for decades and if if
Donald Trump's rhetoric and support for
Donald Trump is is the deciding factor
for you you just haven't been paying
attention and the sort of overarching
themes of the trump presidency a
presidential campaign Rachel are uh
authoritarianism and incompetent but in
reality Trump has moderate beliefs he
have such some beliefs that are more
common among the left he ended up in the
Republican Party because there's no
other path for him Trump would never
have been the Democratic nominee so it's
it's interesting that these people are
leaving the Republican Party because of
Trump but Trump is only in the
Republican primary because of
convenience and that there's no other
path for him well I think there's a
distinction between people who are
saying that oh I'm going to not endorse
him because he's not a real conservative
such as Lionel so so the texas-based ad
manager but in terms of people saying he
says callousness and extremists and
racism there is a difference between
people who want to kind of disowned him
for saying that he's not a real
conservative because of his kind of
brash personality versus actually being
kind of moderate yeah right that there's
so you might say Trump as as it as a
personality is offensive and thus i'm
leaving the republican party that is
different than saying Trump's policy
positions don't reflect mine and now
that he's the Republican nominee there's
clearly no place for my views in the
Republican Party those are very
different circumstances under which
someone might distance themselves from
the party right and if I had to guess
I'd say we're talking about people who
will very quickly rejoin the party once
Donald Trump is out of the picture and
they're more realistic candidates or
realistic what's realistic at this point
B that and and your microphone is of
course on right for sure my microphone
is on be good sometimes I really have
such trouble here yeah I I think I'm
having a hearing issue well maybe yeah
yeah well I get that checked after the
show for now uh we will keep an eye on
the Republican race we will take a break
and we've got a great interview coming
up make sure to give us a like on
facebook facebook.com slash david pakman
show gamefly is sort of like netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4
ps3 wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low use price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
gamefly offer.com / TDPS the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30 day trial for
the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com / TDPS